you can't physically put a person I mean
I've often thought of what a cool movie
would be for example if you go to a war
movie and they out of the screen come
real bullets and you're ducking and you
get out of that where it's not you're
not shielded by the knowledge that I'm
not going to die in this movie house or
that's not the bullets aren't going to
do it and you can't do that that that
you rely as you probably do in anything
you're relying on on the human the
reader the audience's imagination to to
sort of suspend the knowledge that I'm
not going to die inside this book or at
this movie but you almost try to seduce
the reader or the audience into almost
forgetting that almost forgetting that
feel of danger and in a good work of art
there's a movie called a messenger
that's recently come out about the woody
harrelson and Ben Foster it's a but it's
not it's a war movie in a way although
none of it happens in war it's the
notification of next of kin where they
knock on doors and say your son's dad or
your what husband's gone and although
you know in the theater it's not just
know they're actors and so on there's a
bluntness and a brutality and a horror
to it that that some of those way beyond
John Wayne stuff and the actual war
stuff which has a you kind of expect
what's coming and so more people are
going to die and you harden yourself to
it and they do it's a different
experience to watch those knuckles on
the door and that fate door open if that
face that person died in front of you
that mother um that that is what art is
for that's what it's for its for cutting
through rhetoric and cutting through
politics and cutting through convention
to open a trapdoor in your soul
the avowed purposes behind our
preemptive war in Iraq or will get rid
of weapons of mass destruction think I'm
pretty clear on my memory on that well
there weren't any and it's a bit like
let's go to war because we were attacked
at Pearl Harbor it's a Pearl Harbor
hadn't happened and I'm astonished that
its large seems largely forgotten the
seams are erased from the public
discourse about the war I don't hear
many people going on television saying
we went to war for reasons that didn't
exist and I don't I don't feel any
outrage coming from anybody I didn't and
I don't not only do I not feel it now I
never felt it um I find that stunning
and what I do here instead is well we
got rid of a tyrant Saddam was saying
the problem with that is that in the
first place that wasn't the reason we
went to war they did you know Powell
didn't go before the United Nation is
saying let's get rid of a tyrant he went
before saying their weapons of mass
destruction and there was no tyranny
stuff there except in the most
secondhand and trivialized kind of way
more but beyond that you know there's a
thing called consistency there's another
thing called hypocrisy and if the object
is to get rid of tyrants around the
world why aren't we nuking Red China I
hope you stick that the Republicans used
to call Red China and why aren't we at
war with half the countries in Latin
America and why aren't we attacking half
the countries in Africa if not more than
half arm there and there are no answers
to those questions sort of cherry pick
your war and go get rid of that tyrant
and then there's a question of tyrants
in whose eyes mean and what if for
example al-qaeda were to declare George
Bush is a tyrant and we're going to
tacular are we all going to say okay
come tack us it's okay to attack tyrants
who declares that the tire did a zoo we
are we have we been elected as a country
to decide who the tyrants are the good
guys are
those are complicated questions and
they're not addressed they're not even
looked at anymore and it it that's part
of where my frustration comes i think in
writing about this subject as i feel
that things have been d elevated in that
the discourse is aimed at a really low
low low place and difficult questions
are not just not answered they're not
even asked and they aren't asked by Don
seem to have been asked by the people
who uh Turing the bellicose rhetoric of
war it seemed to be alighted Nevada um
and then there's the final issue that
kind of a tender question which is the
issue of a personal how to phrase this
but a personal commitment to one's own
rhetoric that the rhetoric of
bellicosity that sir has surrounded
especially the initial phases of our
intervention in the Middle East if
people aren't there they aren't being we
know the the Cheney's and the the public
face and the public explainers of our
presence that too often they're hiding
their kids away at Yale or you know or
wherever and they're they're not putting
their bodies where their rhetoric is
it's one thing to sit in a TV studio and
your cute bow tie and say let's go kill
people it's not a thing to go and do it
and if you don't go send your daughter
or your son they got to go and they've
got to just go there you know walk the
streets and drive the vehicles and risk
maiming and death and the hypocrisy of
saying it's a great thing to go kill
people but somebody you go do it I'm not
in my kids army you go do it after
having gone through a war myself I fight
that that still stirs in me in the same
way it did 40 years ago
an anger that's hard to it's hard to
keep my voice under control as I'm
talking about it now because it seems so
dishonest and so cowardly and so evil in
the end